STEVE: GOOD EVENING EVERYONE
WELCOME TO "THE NEXT
REVOLUTION" THIS IS THE HOME
OF POSITIVE POPULISM,
PRO-WORKER, PRO-FAMILY,
PRO-COMMUNITY, AND ESPECIALLY
PRO-AMERICA.
IT IS BARELY LED THE WAY IN
MANY PLACES WE DON'T HAVE THIS
LUDICROUS ELECTION MONTH
INSTEAD OF ELECTION DAY.
THE MIDTERMS ARE DAYS AWAY I
AM THE POLITICS GUY INVOLVED
IN ELECTIONS ALL OVER THE
WORLD FOR OVER 30 YEARS AND
HERE IS WHAT I KNOW FOR A
FACT.
AT THIS STAGE IS NOT ABOUT
PERSUASION BUT SENDING OUT THE
AGENDA AND TURNING OUT THE
VOTE IT'S TOO LATE TO PERSUADE
PEOPLE TO SHOW THEM YOUR TOUGH
ON CRIME IF THEY THINK YOU'RE
SOFT ON CRIME OR THAT YOUR
REASONABLE IF THEY THANK YOU
ARE EXTREMELY YOU CAN
INFLUENCE THE AGENDA WHAT IS
FRONT OF MINE FOR VOTERS AS
THEY MAKE THAT CHOICE AT THIS
STAGE THE SALIENCE OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES BUT NOT THE
READINGS BASED ON THAT AND
WHAT I SEE HAPPENING IN THE
CAMPAIGN ARE MY PREDICTIONS
REPUBLICANS WILL MAKE A NET
GAIN OF 15 SEATS THAT'S ENOUGH
FOR A MAJORITY TO TAKE THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE'S TO
GET THOSE INVESTED ON -┘-
INVESTIGATIONS GOING BUT HOUSE
REPUBLICANS DID A GREAT JOB TO
WIN SEATS IN 2020 BUT MAINLY
BECAUSE OF THE MORONIC
MALPRACTICE OF ONE
MAN, LINDSEY GRAHAM WHO WAS
TOTALLY UNNECESSARY INCOHERENT
NATIONAL ABORTION BILL HELP
THE DEMOCRATS DO EXACTLY WHAT
THEY NEED TO RAISE THE
SALIENCE OF THE ONE ISSUE THAT
THE BIGGEST LEAD OVER
REPUBLICANS AND WITS MOST
HELPS THEM TURN OUT THE VOTES
ON THE SENATE I'M A LITTLE
MORE OPTIMISTIC DEMOCRATS HAVE
MADE IT CLEAR IF THEY GAINED
JUST TWO SEATS THEY WILL
ABOLISH THE FILIBUSTER.
I DON'T THINK THAT WILL HAPPEN
BUT HERE IS MY ESTIMATE AS OF
TONIGHT WHAT IS PROBABLE AND
WHAT IS POSSIBLE NOT A
COMPREHENSIVE LIST BUT I THINK
MANY PUNDITS COULD BE GETTING
IT WRONG.
THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO THINK
THEY CAN FLIP OHIO OR
WISCONSIN I AM VERY CONFIDENT
JOHNSON INVENTS AND HERSCHEL
WALKER WILL BEEN IN GEORGIA
THAT WOULD BE HUGE AND I'M
PRETTY CONFIDENT DOCTOR OZ
WILL PULL OUT A WIN IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THERE'S SOME REALLY EXCITING
POSSIBILITIES TO FLIP ENOUGH
DEMOCRATS SEATS TO GAIN A
SOLID SENATE MAJORITY
NEVADA, WASHINGTON, HOW
AMAZING WOULD THAT BE MAYBE
EVEN IN COLORADO.
GREAT CANDIDATES RUNNING
EXACTLY THE RIGHT RACES FOR
THEIR STATE.
OF COURSE ALL OF THIS DEPENDS
ON YOU AND EVERY AMERICAN WHO
WANTS CHANGE FROM THE DEMOCRAT
DISASTERS TO MAKE SURE THEY
VOTE.
BUT THERE IS ONE MORE TO KEEP
AN EYE ON IF YOU THINK THE
REPUBLICAN WIN IN WASHINGTON
STATE IS AN EARTHQUAKE WHAT
ABOUT THE HOME OF BERNIE
SANDERS IN VERMONT?
WROTE OFF COMPLETELY THE
DEMOCRAT RUNNING TO REPLACE
RETIRING PATRICK LEAHY IS THIS
MAN WHO HAS BEEN THE AT-LARGE
CONGRESSMAN THE PAST 16 YEARS.
IS TRYING TO SHOW HE'S A MAN
OF THE PEOPLE BUT WAIT HOW DID
YOU AMASS A
MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR NET WORTH
DESPITE EARNING A
CONGRESSIONAL SALARY?
IT TURNS OUT HE INVESTED IN
HEALTHCARE COMPANIES
BENEFITING FROM THE MAJOR
HEALTHCARE LAW HE PUSHED IN
THE SAME COMPANY PUSHING
$80000 INTO CAMPAIGN COFFERS
AND THEN TRADED BETWEEN
$215,000 ANOTHER HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
PHARMACY STOCK WHILE
LEGISLATION WAS PENDING NOT
ONLY A SINGLE-PAYER BUT A
SINGLE PAYOUT.
HE INVESTED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS INTO TECH FUNDS ALL
WHILE SITTING ON THE
COMMUNICATION AND TECHNOLOGY
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY AFFECTED
THOSE INVESTMENTS HIS FAMILY
INVESTED IN THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY EVEN AS HE RAILED
AGAINST FOSSIL FUELS.
LAST YEAR IN FACT HE WAS FOUND
TO VIOLATE THE ACT OF THE BILL
WHICH HE COSPONSORED AN
UNBELIEVABLY THE VIOLATION WAS
EXXON STOCK BEFORE HE LAID
INTO THE EXXON CEO DURING A
CONGRESSIONAL HEARING ON
CLIMATE.
WELLS THINKS THAT HE IS A
PATAGONIA EATING BEN & JERRY